hi there steve kaufman here
today i want to talk about how to build
a step-by-step study plan for learning
languages
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe you can click on the
bell to get notifications come and join
me at link where i learn languages
so
a study plan i think
for many of the things that are
important to us where we want to achieve
success
it's often considered useful to have a
routine
a study plan some kind of a
of a
set of activities that we feel compelled
to do
so
and i'm going to talk about how that
applies to languages i think the biggest
thing in a study plan is that you want
to develop new habits
all right now i've said many times that
language learning is a matter of of
attitude
and spending the time with the language
so we want to have
habits that reinforce a positive
attitude that give us a sense of success
and we want to have habits that keep us
with the language at the task that's the
kind of study plan that you need to have
and
the the kinds of things you need to do
for a successful study plan for
languages is very similar to other
activities that we would like to you
know do
like getting in shape all right so
little things for example just on the
subject of of people sometimes say to me
steve you seem to be quite fit uh for
your age
what do you eat how do you you know
exercise what's your routine
so
you know throughout my life i have done
i have always you know been jogging
exercising playing hockey playing tennis
keeping active i try to eat
you know healthy food i don't overdo
greasy heavy
you know i always eat healthy bread this
kind of thing
well the same with languages i i wanted
to add too i recently
got an app it's called something about i
can't remember what it is but it's it's
an h-i-i-t high intensive intensity
internal training app and every morning
seven minutes
i do whatever they push at me in the way
of an activity so i'm prompted to do
this and i've now got that as a habit
and i feel
better because every morning for seven
minutes i do this series of exercises so
anything like that can be very
beneficial
i am in the habit of
going to link
for my language learning so people are
going to complain i always promote link
but i do because that's what i do i get
up in the morning
i go to whatever course i'm on
i go play the course audio and while
preparing breakfast i will be listening
to that course
this is then going to push me
to read because there inevitably are
portions of that
lesson or several lessons that i
listened to
that i didn't understand and of course i
can either shuffle
the lessons or simply go through them in
order
typically if i'm well along
in that
course i'll shuffle them but if i'm
still trying to learn new words i'll go
in order
so that's a habit that i have
so i think that the study plan in in
language learning
is more about
your mindset
the habits you create rather than spend
a half hour here a half hour there
because
so much of language learning is
subjective it's emotional i think it's
important to engage in the activities
that we enjoy doing that we feel we want
to do at this particular moment
so i have found that listening
tends to trigger a lot of other
activities for me so it's very simple
for me i just turn on the listening now
i want to
look up you know read what i listen to
look up words
and that kind of thing but another thing
that's important in terms of a study
plan is to make sure you surround
yourself with the resources that you
need
so
obviously content
and i've mentioned many times that in an
initial period that is going to be sort
of repetitious listening to relatively
simple content with a lot of repeated
you know vocabulary especially high
frequency verbs
at a later stage you're listening more
out of interest but you have to find
this content of interest you have to
find the content this repetitive content
so you there is some work to be done
there
i find it useful to buy one or several
starter books because it's nice to hold
a book in your head
you have to find some
grammar resources that you can refer to
whether it be online or in a book so
part of a study plan is to make sure you
surround yourself with the resources you
need you're going to need
an mp3 player you're going to need um
obviously uh internet access to go and
find these resources
um
that's got to be part of your study plan
in fact i end up spending a fair amount
of my sort of time that i devote to
language learning looking for
content for
persian and arabic it's difficult to
find
interesting content at my level
much easier to do say in english or
probably in spanish
but
part of your study plan
has got to be to prepare yourself i i
will often go and get
content and and make sure i've got it
imported into links so that i have it
ready so that when i want to go and
listen i've got enough content in front
of me
so part of your study plan has to be
devoting enough time to
preparing the content you're going to
use
grammar resources i mentioned also at a
certain stage in your language learning
you're going to want to speak more
and if you're not if you don't live
where the language is spoken you're
going to have to find some online
people to either exchange the language
with or tutors
and i've mentioned italki which i have
used we have tutors that think but
you've got to find someone to speak to
and eventually again
to my mind in any sort of plan of
language learning activity
the amount of speaking you do is going
to increase over time because in the
first period you have to kind of break
the code of the language you have to get
some familiarity with the language
people often say well if you don't know
anything how can you get started well
that's why you deal with very short bits
of content where you have access to an
online dictionary i wouldn't want to be
looking up every word in a dictionary
i find link very convenient in that
regard with our many stories lots of
repetition
slowly you get a foothold in the
language that's the first stage but at a
later stage you're listening to things
that are more interesting and at that
point you want to start speaking you
want to start speaking
because
you want to try out what you've learned
you'll find out that you aren't able to
recall a lot of the words that that you
know passively so you have to get in
there and start speaking
speaking without worrying about the
mistakes you make
and so that
speaking is got to be part of that study
plan and what i find particularly useful
when i have my sessions with my tutors
at link is that i get a report from them
of 10 or 15 words and phrases that i had
trouble with and i have this as a record
going back a year two years i can always
go back to
a lesson that we had and things that i
struggled with and of course my tutors
record this for me so that's also very
you know that sort of
that way of using
your online uh you know discussions or
sessions with your tutor is also very
useful so
i guess my approach to this idea of a
study plan
is that it's it's not so much sort of
very specific you know 20 minutes there
half an hour there because that's going
to vary depending on your interests what
you like to do some people maybe like to
go through and key
i think you want to be guided by by what
you enjoy doing
and because that's going to keep your
attitude positive it's going to keep you
liking it it's going to keep you
spending enough time with it so
it's more a matter of preparing yourself
trying to develop
good habits
trying to develop habits that push you
into the language push you along until
you find
enough compelling content that that's
now starting to pull you along and then
at some point
when you start speaking
be prepared to make mistakes recognize
that that it's only in making mistakes
that you're going to get better that
you're eventually going to make fewer
mistakes so
you know
people have asked me for this what's a
step-by-step sort of plan for language
learning
i i'm not sure i think that i've often
said that language learning is more of a
fuzzy logic thing than a step-by-step
thing
uh you might want to go to one of my
videos where i say that language
learning is a subjective
process
i've also done a video on the stages
you know the different stages we passed
through in our language learning i think
both of these videos might be worthwhile
to go and have a look at so
thank you for listening
and good luck with your language
learning bye for now